(audience chatter)
- Optimism.
I'm gonna be on a
Snapchat optimism kick.
I'm sorry. It just hit me.
Optimism. I'm fucking
selling optimism.
It's the Optimism Unicorn!
It's the
Optimism Unicorn, DRock.
Have you ever seen one before?
It's rare.
- Thank you.
- You keep asking questions,
we'll keep (audio cuts out).
Love it. Let's move
forward to the selfie and
get the hell out of here.
- Thank you. Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
Where?
- Yep.
- [Garrett] Gary, can I show
you something real quick?
- We gotta roll, we gotta roll,
we gotta roll.
- "House of Cards", load up
I want to put a quote there.
(inaudible)
We already did "Go do."
Do you want something else?
- [Gary] Yeah, I do.
Because if you want something
you don't have that much time.
- [Front Desk Woman] Gary!
- [Gary] Yes, hey!
- How you doin'?
- [Gary] Good. How are you?
That guy bumped into me,
I almost got in to a fight.
Or, you know,
maybe as I get older,
something with the eyes,
I'm getting older
I'm starting to realize I'm
more like you kind of thing.
You know?
I'm thinking about putting
a Facebook post of
the video and the entire
article in like one post.
The video accompanied
by the long form text.
I want to try that.
Being in there, there's some
reason you guys want that
but I want way more pro
and con reactions (censored).
The first one's perfect.
(censored) is perfect.
That's the kind of stuff
I want more of.
Marketing talk and referencing
marketing is not interesting.
And the other thing we can do,
just as a strategy,
they mention the brand but
we go back 5 or 10 tweets
and we find out they're trying
to make the
basketball team. Right?
And we get (censored)
to surprise him
and help him practice.
I'm a big believer that a name
is nothing until you make it.
Nobody knew what Google
or Facebook or Nike meant
until it was made.
This campaign is going to be
meaningful to their business
because of how we execute more
so than the hashtag
or the theme.
You know what I mean?
And they're both great.
To me, I just want to
give everybody context
to how I roll if I get
more involved in stuff
like this is I'm more in the
"no" business than
the "yes" business.
You know what I mean?
For me, if something's just
so insane and I'm like,
"What the hell?"
Listen, I'm crazy so that's
never gonna happen.
Because it's difficult
for people to wrap
their head around it after
you've been branded
in their mind.
I think it requires
enormous amounts of
humility and patience for the
person that's going through it
and I will give you
one other thing
and I think this is probably
the crux of the article for me
if I was reading it
the biggest problem is people
are trying to rebrand themselves
in something they're not good at
or capable of doing.
I'd love to be a rapper.
I'd love to rebrand
myself a rapper.
I was actually a
marketing and business guy
which is why it was easy for me
to transition from
a wine personality.
But if I try next week to
position myself as a
hip hop artist,
I've got a problem.
And I think I'm seeing a
lot of people trying to
re-position themselves
as entrepreneurs or
as thought leaders
in certain genres
when they are actually not that.
I'm feeling it a lot
because of entrepreneurship.
Everybody wants to be an
entrepreneur even though they
never sold anything
in their god damn lives.
Now, that doesn't
mean you can't be.
But before you start branding
I think there is a very distinct
thing I'm about to tell you.
I would rebrand myself as
somebody who's going through
the journey of becoming an
entrepreneur versus branding
myself as an entrepreneur.
Got it?
And I think that's the
powerful distinction.
I think people are
faking the funk.
I think people are way too
bought into faking it
until you make it.
Faking until you make it will
make worked when
nobody was watching.
Something I don't think I talk
a lot with you guys about this
whole fake it 'til you make it
thing which I think was a really
good strategy for a long period
of time the problem right now
is so many of you are
faking it in public.
Fake it 'til you make it was
great 'cause nobody was watching
and you were faking it by doing
it and you were learning,
you were learning on the job is
probably the more
noble way to say it.
The problem is so many of you
now are saying you're there
before you're there.
We encountered that
yesterday again in Denver.
Lovely kid.
"Why am I not
making money?"
You're not selling anything.
That's it's most basic
form of entrepreneurship.
You're just not there yet.
You may get there.
So I think it is super
important for people to start
understanding what's really
happening in the ecosystem which
is so many of you are projecting
a personality in social and it
just really matters that
there's something behind it.
And that's kind of personal
brands is what we were
talking about there.
Please, that little distinction
and replay it right now DRock,
I want you to do the
(buzzing).
(tape rewinding)
So many of you are projecting
a personality in social and it
just really matters that
there's something behind it.
There's a distinction between,
there's a very big distinction
between I'm going through the
journey of becoming this
and I am this.
And way too many of you
are saying I am this
and nobody believes you.
(light music)
- [Tim] Hey, I'm Tim.
- Hey. Tim.
- [Tim] Nice to meet you.
- Such a pleasure.
How are you?
- Thanks for coming.
- I'm good.
- Thanks for having me.
- How's your day?
- Good.
- Cool.
- How's it going?
- It's good.
- So who's in the crowd?
- Who's in the crowd?
It is about 20% enterprise,
40% mid-market
and the rest is SMB.
- On selling mainly B2B?
- Mainly B2B.
- Like 90%.
- Right.
- [Man] Huge fan.
- Thank you, brother.
What's your name?
- Peter.
- Peter, thank you.
- Good to meet you, man.
- Nice to meet you.
Thank you.
- Looking forward to your talk.
- Thank you so much.
My point of view on how to use
all the new tools that I'm good
at from a B2B
sales point of view.
- [Tim] Right.
- I'm introducing you.
- How are you, brother?
- Patrick Blair,
nice to meet you.
- Really nice to meet you.
How are you?
- Thanks for doing this.
- Yeah, I'm thrilled to be here.
- This is great stuff.
- Thank you, man.
Salespeople are easy.
You give them a target,
they reverse,
you can make their
actions, right?
- [Patrick] Right, right, right.
- I'm just curious what
people are actually doing.
Are they cold emailing or
are they just linking up with
everybody on
LinkedIn and hoping?
Are they...
- [Patrick] (inaudible)
From what I see,
- Yeah.
- [Patrick] what are you thinking?
Are you a human?
- Yeah.
- [Patrick] I tell our guys
that all the time--
- You're preaching.
- [Patrick] if you send your
buddy that email,
does he respond to it?
- You're not responding to it.
- [Patrick] That's
not humans speak.
- You mean the cold
email that has--
- [Patrick] The cold email.
The cold call.
- I am. Yeah.
- [Patrick] Hi Gary. May
speak to you for a minute?
That's not how you
speak to someone.
- I know where to go.
(light music)
- Thank you. Appreciate it.
- Awesome, man.
Thank you.
Thanks for having me.
- Good luck.
- And the truth is and I know
those four very well
Fredrik I think is a
purebred salesman
but I really do think that I was
born very lucky in that I think
my parents are very opposite and
I think I feel very in kinship
with my marketing and with my
sales and so that's what I want
to focus on because I think a
lot of people here can
make a lot more money if they
eliminated two things:
one, laziness to be very frank,
and, two, idealistic
points of view of how
they've made their
money in the past.
I think one of the biggest
concerns I have sitting here in
a world where I'm hungry to get
one to two people, three people
to get a lot of value out of
this talk is the way you made
your money before is my enemy.
The way you've been successful
yesterday is my enemy.
It is stunning if you understood
what runs through my head every
morning on how to little I think
anybody should give a fuck about
anything I achieved
yesterday back.
The biggest problem is people
get, the reason why I've been
successful on the boards and
NGO and you know of my work is
'cause I brought business
DNA to the nonprofit sector.
Let's eliminate the romance.
Don't tell me the fluff.
Tell me that I'm going to save
$17,000 a year by giving you
$25,000 and I'll
write you $50,000.
Got it?
- [Woman] Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
(applause)
- Thank you guys.
Bye guys.
- Look, here's the thing--
- Yeah.
- I know I've been in
business development--
- Yes.
- but I have more
balls and desire to do it.
- DRock, do me a favor it's
time to give him an at-bat.
Get me 25 minutes at the office.
Let me give it real thought.
- Okay.
- So that was awesome.
- Thank you.
I think I might get
fired if I ask this,
how many fucks do you give?
You don't have to
sacrifice sleep for hustle.
You have to sacrifice entire
seasons of "House of Cards".
You have to
sacrifice Candy Crush.
You have to sacrifice being
on the bowling and dart and
softball team if
you want big results.
Headed to
Cleveland for the game.
That should be a lot of fun.
Little networking
business action.
That will be fun.
Really good day, this was
a great conference.
I just spoke at
Sales Machine 16.
Did a good job guys, seriously.
Really good stuff.
- [Tim] Thank you, Gary.
Appreciate it.
- You're welcome.
Great crowd.
Sales, I talk so much about
marketing and branding
that I miss the sales part so
it's fun to kind of dust off
some of those chops.
Good day had some really
intense, solid meetings today.
Got some really good stuff done.
Misha's school had a graduation,
so did a little family time.
A nice little kind of family,
branding and
running a business day.
Typical.
(light hip hop music)